this happened you bad [__]
making Joey here christening the new
[__] bong I said you know what I'm
gonna christen is no bomb I gotta call
my peeps because they're gonna be
excited if I [__] hit the bottom like
uncle Joey this is the we were smoking
last night the white this [__] will
[__] kill a [__] moose you
understand me
this shit's got all the [__] powers
and I'm telling you right now plus it
fell in my [__] little box and I had
to scrape it up with pennies and [__] so
it's got all that [__] from the pennies
and toenails and [__] tremendous
and a way for the wind
what the [__] what's wrong with this
[__] wind here
ah that's what we're talking about he
had a respect for you [__] I'm
gonna christen new bow [__] not
a rock
don't even ask what happened to the
other one two of them got [__]
clicked already understand me I forget
it's so [__] high on the bat in the
washer man I leave him there people
[__] good I'm in the office those
[__] but no more putting a
[__] tracker on this [__] now
I'm gonna know where it's at every
minute I'm come on to here I'm gonna
crack these [__] like like I
don't know who you understand me
oh yeah nice very nice I can feel the
[__] effects already in my eyeballs
you understand me
not only getting stoned and feeling the
heat in your [__] eyeballs like what
the [__] going on
I got x-ray vision [__] but this
is what it is I ran my little errands I
went to my meeting you like a little
half a [__] [__] purple shirt what do
you do when you meet with these Gentiles
you gotta look like them if not they
look at you like you got [__] 300
understand so where my little purple
half a flag should ever be smiles ha ha
ha
they drink water they offer you water
you know the [__] deal but I'm back
I'm done for the day getting ready for
the six o'clock [__] podcast
we're going deep deep deep like Madonna
in 93
deeper and deeper
[__] a little and gotta bring
industrious
very nice this weed is so good I'm
[__] sweating you understand me but
that's what it's supposed to do when you
smoke they're [__] we supposed to
break up these [__] things in your
brain and [__]
is my poker
I'm very [__] a little mad with
maintenance I don't go for that [__]
everybody else goes for I have to do
this and that I have to do dick oh you
got to smoke reefer eat somebody's
[__] and do jumping jacks and you'll
live to your [__] 90 understand me
oh yeah we're gonna fill this [__]
bong nicely I even see some cat hairs in
there and [__] tremendous you have a
smoke cat here [__] you up for two days
anyway it's a beautiful day to be alive
I hope today's being great deal I hope
he left the house would [__] it yep I
got you fired up this morning
ah nice don't forget to buy the book
briefed by dr. beliefs get your life
together get your breathing game
together get your bonnet game together
nobody wants to hang out what people
can't do a [__] monkey understand me
bong gets all [__] day long if you're
not doing bondage you won't be invited
to my [__] christening he understand
me
you guys stole until he kills blade hey
it's my treat I'm sitting in it I'm not
[__] crying
it's very nice that we get to do this in
the afternoons in the morning smoke some
reefer together reminisce about the old
days and just get stung like [__]
family that's it that's all I've ever
asked was a family got took my family I
get that all I ever wanted
what's your definition of the family
Jordan people you can sit with like a
smoke we be at the bar real quick tank
give me right to the airport and show me
[__] love the same love and respect I
give you that's fan let's like give you
guys not the loving [__] respect you
know why cuz you're an animal like me
you know that way like the regular
[__] people people laugh with us in
this [__] they don't like this I don't
give a [__] if I'm the Addams Family I
swing digging joy which would be a beet
do the [__] bong and shut your
[__] mouth that's what this reefer
makes me do is talk like that did 22
kilos of blow
very nice let's do one more and we'll
call it an afternoon I'll see you guys
tonight over at the office the Voodoo
Lounge the original before the [__]
Rolling Stones you understand me I love
the smell of reefer in the afternoon
and that's it and that's that you know
pregnancy there all day with child
[__] camera local joint for Johnny
well who's got that type of time watch a
few movies maybe the salad something but
this is my favorite activity it's
smoking reefer with my family that's it
you don't you ever do like a [__] pit
yeah what's your favorite exhibit yeah I
like hugging him and snowboarding listen
now I sit around with three [__]
dudes and smoking reefer til somebody
dies you understand me couple wings some
who cheese some [__] diet coke some
waters and that's it everything else is
[__] whenever you see on TV these
guys at tuxedos I'm a good time with
vodka I go suck my dick all right you
give me three guys announcer just weed
in the bomb I'll show you giggles more
those [__] four [__] malt balls at
the bar on me in these [__] animals
understand me anyway I'm feeling very
Jewish today at the Star of David on my
[__] nutsack [__] that's the
heat I'm [__] drone today what
hold on the [__] plane I do a bunk
and I might knock him out of the [__]
air
[Music]
and that's it and that's that was a good
pocket I felt like I got pushing ahead
with brought last 922 steroids but
anyway you know I love you [__]
I'll see you tonight absolutely we're
doing a pre Church we always do a pre
church that's a massive we got some
stars we got everything tonight we got
nine different types of weed you know we
don't [__] around all right
I got you [__] don't ever forget
that all these other [__] they
pull [__]
uncle Joey's from the [__] low down
low down what we got is us that's it I
don't know nothing else I don't know no
I told you that thousand I don't know
nothing I don't know nobody I don't know
what you're talking about no what the
[__] you want even know why I'm here
anyway
I love you guys I'll see you tonight
don't forget about all right I see in
Denver this weekend whatever the [__]
you want to do you know y'all will see
it stay black that's it